from quentin hey michael i have a
question this might be dumb what is the
christian view on anime girl pillows
huh
hypothetically speaking if one were to
use it as a sleep aid like for sleep
who would that be wrong on one hand it's
a pillow so it should not be a problem
on the other hand there is an anime girl
on it so it might be considered wrong
keep in mind this is only hypothetical
i'm going to do something i usually
don't have a computer in front of me but
we were snowed home over the past few
days so i usually keep no chords i don't
like having screens in front of me
during the show but i do have a computer
which means that i'm here i'm gonna put
on my like
my expressvpn right now i can't i don't
wanna have this typed into my google
history anime girl
pillow
what is an anime
okay well that makes sense it's just a
pillow of an anime girl but they're long
it's like a full body pillow okay well
if if you have this pillow
quentin because you just really like the
artwork and you just really appreciate
the art and the beauty of the anime girl
pillow
i guess that's fine
a little weird but fine
if you have this
full lady sized cartoon lady pillow
that you hold in your sleep
for some less wholesome reason
that would not be fine that would be
probably a near occasion of sin
and appeal to the prurient interest and
throw out the pillow buddy don't that's
don't have the pillow that's i've okay
i'm i'm not going to be i'm changed my
mind just no just no no pillows none of
that i'm so glad that you liked that
clip it's great it's wonderful to have
you to be with you to welcome you into
my
private study in my head it feels very
intimate if you want to keep up that
intimacy
ring the bell subscribe then you'll get
notifications head on over to apple
podcast but if i stitch your google play
wherever you get your audio podcast type
in the michael knowles show
subscribe leave a five star review see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]